well maybe you did a lot of decorating
for the holidays over the weekend it was
chilly in the mornings but the
afternoons were nice
then we started getting clouds yesterday
and those clouds have been sticking
around
and that's made a difference with our
temperatures this morning lots of 40s
around the las vegas valley
so those extra cold 30's like we had
over the weekend
remember last week when we had 20s in
the prom valley and out at red rock
this morning we're in the 40s in those
places kingman just a little above
freezing at 35.
mesquite's a little cool at 36 and we
still have north winds
along the colorado river valley in
laughlin that has been really a stubborn
pattern
the jet stream way up around the
canadian border
dipping down into new england and new
england had its first
nor'easter of the season over the
weekend they were getting the snow plows
out and they were shoveling the wet
chilly snow check this out we don't have
to shovel sunshine we say it all the
time but boy this was a very different
scene
and very typical for this time of year
in the northeast part of the country
they had up to a foot
of wet snow and sometimes winds up to 60
miles an hour in connecticut
massachusetts in those states and the
northeast
so we've got clouds we've had some very
light virgo rain
areas like indian springs nothing though
that's actually touching the ground
and eventually these clouds will shift
to the south we'll be left with some
good afternoon sunshine
highs up near 70 degrees today but north
winds
about 15 to 20 miles an hour through the
afternoon tomorrow looks beautiful 67
and sunny
a few clouds return on wednesday first
evening of hanukkah looks great
sundown will be cool we'll be in those
low
60s but we'll get some 50s by friday
saturday that's another cool system with
more wind
to finish the week but pretty normal
really too